I have paid attention to my life because
I understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you try to
pull the company and have it succeed is
like eating glass and staring into the
abyss I was never the one to like chase
the sector oh this is hot because you
have to ask yourself who are you
competing with and whatever you do you
have to ask yourself what's your edge
wanna be happy
build a life not just a business hey
Sarah Carmichael and this channel was
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believed
life and learn the differences between
how billionaires think compared to the
rest of the world
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one they aim to be the best versions of
themselves with Oprah Winfrey I have
paid attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you where you
are in the language with the people with
the circumstances and experiences that
you can understand and interpret if you
are willing to see that always life God
is speaking to you now it took me a
while to actually really get this and to
understand it but once I did I started
paying attention to everything and one
of the reasons why I can now accept the
fact that I can offer my
gatherings of information and wisdom and
call myself a spiritual teacher is that
every single person who ever came on my
show and I hear there's like 37,000
guests I've talked to a lot of them came
from dysfunction and a lot of them
wouldn't appear to be teachers but every
one of them had something to say that
was meaningful and valuable and that I
could use to grow myself into the best
of myself which is what all of our jobs
are your number one job is to become
more of yourself and to grow yourself
into the best of yourself rule number
two they are very patient with Warren
Buffett in business I swing at easy
pitches I stand at the plate and if I
like pitches one inch above my navel
right in the center of the plate I can
wait and wait and wait because there's
no called strikes you know there as long
as that that's on my shoulder nobody's
calling a strike if the pitcher throws
me general motors at 36 IBM at 82
Microsoft at 25 and I don't swing it's
not a strike it's not a hit either but
it's not a strike
I only when I swing is it a strike so I
wait for easy pitches I wait for things
I understand they're exactly in my sweet
spot also if you want to have more
confidence and self love check out my
250 for series they're free the link to
join on your description below becomes
so skilled so vigilant so flat-out
fantastic at what you do that your
talent cannot be dismissed there are
just times when something is important
enough you believe it enough that you do
you do it in spite of the fear if
everything has to work in two to three
years then that limits what you can do
rule number three they are prepared to
tolerate pain with Elon Musk there's a
friend of mine he's got a great saying
about creating a company which is
creating turnable the company and have
it succeed is like eating glass and
staring into the abyss so I mean what
tends happen is it's sort of quite
exciting for the first several months of
starting a company and then then reality
sets in things don't go as well as
and customers aren't signing up the
technology of the part isn't working as
well as you thought and and then can
that concerns be compounded by a
recession and it could be very very
painful for several years so I think
frankly starting a company you know I
would advise people to have a high pain
tolerance rule number four find a
competitive edge with Mark Cuban I was
never the one to like chase the sector
oh this is hot because you have to ask
yourself who are you competing with and
whatever you do you have to ask yourself
what's your edge right what is the one
thing that gives you a competitive edge
if you don't have an answer
you can't start that company you're
gonna lose right I said before if you're
trying to compete with me you better low
know a whole lot more than I do about
whatever business were in because
otherwise I'm gonna kick your ass right
so you have to ask yourself what is your
competitive advantage and with that kick
competitive advantage what's the best
way for me to get customers who are
willing to write me a check might one of
my skill sets has always been I've been
able to walk into any type of business
and understand their company you know
understand how they make money I
understand how they compete so I can
walk into a shoe store I can walk into a
hospital or whatever and say alright
here's my technology here's how it gives
you an advantage and I try to do the
same thing a shark tank you hear say it
all the time
what is your competitive advantage just
saying it's my passion
do you ever walk into 7-eleven and say
wow I'm shopping here at 7-eleven
because they're really passionate no
right and when when you go and you make
your think about your own buying
decisions what makes you decide to buy
now you might want to support veteran
owned business so I always when it's a
toss-up yes right but at some point you
have to grow beyond the community and
you have to be able to say like you can
walk into any situation and know without
any doubt in your mind this is why you
are the best product or service
you are the best company provide that
product or service period in a story if
you can't do that you have to ask
yourself who is doing it what are they
doing that gives them that edge what
allows them to compete or help their
customers better than you can right cuz
that's what it's all about we all as
consumers make buying decisions and we
the people who are buying our stuff is
product or service use the same thought
process for those buying decisions so
always put yourself in your potential
customers shoes what is it that I have
that makes it a no-brainer for them to
buy for me if it's um nice I'm
passionate you're in trouble right
there's got to be something because even
if you can get some customers how are
you going to grow it how are you going
to sustain it and what's going to keep
the next person from coming in and doing
the same thing because look with success
comes additional challenges the more you
succeed the more people say damn okay
that's an opportunity I think I can do
that better and so success isn't look
where I'm at
success is go-go-go-go right I mean
people say wow you've done this I'm
still going right to me business is the
ultimate sport and there's nobody on the
face of the earth that's more
competitive than I am I've said that to
Magic Johnson Michael Jordan Larry Bird
you name it right
any athlete any businessperson it is the
ultimate sport and we're competing all
the time what is it that gives you an
edge that allows you to compete how do
you sustain that and how do you find
more people that say yes to buy that
that is going to be the key to your
business and how do you sell it rule
number five they take bold bets Jeff
Bezos my job one of my jobs as the
leader of Amazon is to encourage people
to be bold and people love to focus on
things that aren't yet working and
that's good it's human nature that kind
of divine discontent can be very helpful
but you really you know it's
incredibly hard to get people to take
full bets and you need to encourage that
and if you're gonna take bold bets
they're gonna be experiments and if
they're experiments you don't know ahead
of time go they're going to work
experiments are by their very nature
prone to failure but big success is a
few big successes compensate for dozens
and dozens of things that didn't work so
you know bold bets AWS Kindle Amazon
Prime our 3rd party seller business all
of those things are examples of bold
bets that that did work and they pay for
a lot of experiments I've made billions
of dollars of failures at Amazon calm
literally billions of dollars of
failures and you know you might remember
pets calm or Cosmo or you know give
myself a root canal with no anesthesia
very easily none of those things are fun
but but they also they don't matter what
really matters is companies that don't
continue to experiment companies that
don't embrace failure they eventually
get in a desperate position where they
only thing they can do is make a kind of
Hail Mary bet at the very end of their
corporate existence
whereas companies that are you know
making bets all along even you know big
bets but not bet the company bets I
don't I don't believe in bet the company
bets that's when you're desperate that's
that's the last thing you can do and
rule number six the last one before a
very special bonus clip is they're
always positive with John Paul DeJoria
so of all the things in the world that
you could say are like the secrets that
being positive is one of the main things
that people need to do how did you
happen on that in life whether it's
personal or people around me when you
see people that are positive that look
at something good and something bad that
took place they move along in life
faster they're veteran and people want
to be around these people I mean too
often people gossip the one gossip
person must be around the other person
that gossips but they don't realize when
you gossip you're saying something heard
about somebody else you're telling
everybody
what if part of it was wrong you had to
go out and tell every person you told
this oh I'm sorry it was wrong tell
everybody you told it's not gonna happen
so it seems you learn about don't gossip
don't belittle people if you don't have
to god please don't try and look at the
positive angle what good could come out
of something and that possum Ness is
gonna make you live longer happier and
wake up in the morning happy not oh my
god I got I got a work I can't wait till
I get home I want to retire because
people are not positive they were not
happy and what happens they retire they
hate their job they retire three or four
years later their debts they have
nothing to do that positive attitude be
around positive people encourage
positiveness if you find yourself
walking around just complaining all the
time around people that complain a lot
man move or just try and do something
different change your life being
positive and a positive attitude is find
something positive and something bad
makes you look for solutions when I was
down and out okay who opop bottles let's
get the pop bottles cash them in now I
have a special bonus tip from Jack Ma on
how to see challenges as opportunities
that I think you're going to enjoy but
before that is time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching the video to take an action
here we go question number one where do
you need to be more positive in your
business or life number two what's the
next bold bet that you need to take and
number three where do you need to be
more patient and if you liked this video
and promised you take action after
watching it give me a hashtag believe
down in the comments as well we don't
just watch videos here we do something
about it so give me a hashtag believe
make that promise to yourself and then
get to work this world today so full of
challenges and opportunities 2,000 years
ago full of challenges and opportunities
and I'm sure 2,000 years later
full of challenges and opportunities
there is always it depends on how you
look at
somebody look at this challenge as
opportunity young people we say there's
no opportunity I complain a lot when I
was young because I think Bill Gates
took opportunities for the Microsoft and
Steve Jobs all these guys there's no job
there's no great big stuff left for us
but I think opportunity always lies in
the challenges always lies in the
complaints if you can solve the
challenge you have there you will be
successful
the big challenge you solve the big
problem or the big opportunity you have
if you want to know the five morning
routines that are critical for success
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there there's a
rule there's thirty minutes I cannot
touch my telephone when I wake up that's
the hardest thing to do in the world and
the thing that could benefit you the
most it's really important to certain
everyday